from one character here with a special
gift to the forthcoming Suicide Squad
you've played a superior before in
Hancock and all three characters have
dubious morals but how would you say
each differs oh wow that's interesting I
think I think how do they differ that's
interesting I hadn't even thought about
those as one I guess I like the concept
of dubious morals I always like the to
play in that area but the character and
focus his issue is he is committed to
lying right he is committed to wearing a
mask and no one ever knowing who he is
and the idea that you can't have love if
if you're lying you know you can't have
that that thing that we all search for
if you're not being authentic and living
without the mask so morally he's he's
made a decision that being a liar is the
only way he can survive he protects
himself absolutely with Hancock Hancock
doesn't remember so that's an
interesting thing also not having any
memory of who he was he has no idea what
his moral standing was and then suicide
squad that's interesting I was a we just
got started on that and I think I
haven't explored the the psychology
enough of Deadshot somebody who can take
money to kill people how he justifies
that for for himself so I still I still
have a little bit to work work to do on
that but in my life in general and in my
career those are the types of roles that
I'm pushing more towards those kinds of
questions you know what was interesting
for me with focus now is in my life my
journey is around vulnerability and
authenticity so to have a guy who has
just decided to lie was really
interesting to test the the boundaries
of how wide open and how authentic can I
be in real life by exploring the other
side in the character
you